i can think of a number of people that
um i would love to hear you interview
and here i'm not revealing the reasons
why but except for the fact that i think
you would be uniquely suited to bring
out the important components of the
conversation that other people have not
been able
to
uh do which for instance liz holmes this
is one of the most
mysterious and yet disliked people
on the planet
um
she's sort of synonymous with deception
i don't know if there have been any
real interviews of her since the whole
thing
i haven't followed that case i listened
to the book and i
i followed it a little bit because it
was happening in my hometown right
theranos was right up the road the
building's still there it's interesting
it's it's some of the most premier real
estate in silicon valley but nobody
wants it it's like it's very hard to
sell a home where somebody committed
suicide or committed a murder even if
it's a beautiful home so i feel like the
theronos building is that building um
so that would be a really interesting
interview i would love to hear that
interview one of the most interesting
dark human beings in science
yeah and then there will even be people
that say you know um was it even science
right it might have all been deception
it might have been one part deception
one part
goal setting mixed in with clearly that
there were
so many factors impacting what happened
um i think the big difference between
theranos and
that story and some of the other stories
about silicon valley where people
promised a lot more than they could
deliver is they were promising things
that were directly related to health and
health care people were taking blood
tests with the understanding that the
data they were getting was important
information about sexually transmitted
diseases and other diseases and making
real world decisions on the basis of
that whereas if you remember when the
iphone first came out and steve jobs was
still alive and the phones were dropping
calls if you held it in a particular way
and his response was a little flip he
said
hey folks it's a phone as if like don't
get so worked up but people held them
understandably to a very high standard
you know she would
sort of it seemed and i don't know
because i certainly wasn't there seemed
like she sort of
adopted this idea that you could get it
wrong a bunch of times before you get it
right
except if the allegations are true and i
think they she was found guilty i
believe on a number of accounts
that a number of the things that they
were doing were were impacting real
world decision making where so steve's
point about the phone is just a phone
well depends on the call if you're
calling 9-1-1 then it's not just a phone
right but in the case of blood tests and
disease you know that's that's serious i
think that the theranost case was super
interesting to me because of the number
of people from major universities and
from government
that
both trusted her and the number of
people who did not trust her and yet
either didn't speak up or no one
listened to them it was only in the
forensic version of it that everyone
said oh yeah i knew that she was lying
etc etc they were lying there are
multiple people involved in those lies
apparently but i have a deep interest in
the neuroscience of of narcissism
sociopathy and some of the darker
aspects of the mind so yeah maybe
someday well maybe we'll do a podcast
together yeah maybe like in the in the
in the kind of early 90s version of talk
shows where we darken the lights and we
yeah we do it together you can use your
voice because your voice is much more
sinister sounding than mine
good cop bad cop uh well it'd be
interesting from a scientific
perspective of somebody who is
a sociopath or psychopath
how to reveal something
real about them i think
that requires not just well i don't know
what that requires that requires the
same skill that it takes to be a good
therapist
right and some therapists won't work
with sociopaths because
they don't feel any progress can be made
some therapists will work with
sociopaths because for the wealthy ones
they often
they want their money
i i think most therapists are good and
benevolent but there are some that will
do it just same way lawyers will work
with criminals knowing they're criminals
right
oftentimes because they're criminals
there are certain domains of psychiatry
that are
more tractable than others right
borderlines are interesting i should
just mention because they have this
phenomenon of splitting so in the in the
world of psychology the idea is that
being neurotic
is actually the goal the idea that you
could be
um you know feel something and then work
a lot to overcome it or um have some
sort of defense mechanism in place but
that's not destructive that's actually a
pretty healthy state to be in it's uh
provided it's not destructive
psychotic is
truly delusional thinking about reality
and the idea is that borderline split
intermittently split between psychotic
and neurotic that's why it's called this
beautiful work by melanie klein that
describes this which i'm just now kind
of delving into but you know so the
borderline is the person who is like i
love you i love you i love you and then
truly feels as if they hate you and you
become the bad object
um borderlines are challenging for
psychologists because of the splitting
right um
schizophrenics are challenging because
of the the
detachment from reality and narcissists
are challenging because they're often so
charming
that even the therapists are charmed
you